>> Bret:
>> I'M SAYING THIS PRESIDENT HAS
DONE A HORRIBLE THING.
AND NOT STANDING UP AND SPEAKING
THE TRUTH ARE SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENT IN A WAY THAT
THEM, WHAT HAVE YOU.
SO WHEN I SAID I STAND BY MY
STAND UP.
MAKE YOUR VOICE HEARD AND
EXPLAINED WHY YOU THINK THEY ARE
WRONG AND YOU ARE RIGHT.
SHOULD CALL FOR THE HARASSMENT
OF POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
DEMOCRATS THOUGHT THAT MAXINE
WATERS DID OVER THE WEEKEND,
REACTING TO THE STORY ABOUT
SARAH SANDERS BEING THROWN OUT
OF THE RESTAURANT IN VIRGINIA.
YOU NEED TO TELL THEM THEY ARE
NOT WELCOME ANYWHERE, ANYMORE.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING OUT ABOUT
EXTRAORDINARILY LOW IQ PERSON,
AS COME TOGETHER WITH
NANCY PELOSI.
SHE HAS JUST CALLED FOR HARM FOR
SUPPORTERS, OF WHICH THERE ARE
MANY INDIAN MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN MOVEMENT.
BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR,
MAX."
WHAT DO WE THINK ABOUT ALL THIS?
CHARLES HERBERT, OPINION EDITOR
FOR "THE WASHINGTON TIMES" ."
CHARLIE?
>> YOU KNOW YOU HAVE PROBABLY
GONE TOO FAR WHEN YOU HAVE
CHUCK SCHUMER AND NANCY PELOSI
PULLING HER CHAIN BACK A LITTLE
BIT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S TOUGH.
I KNOW THAT THIS IS THE KIND OF
THING THAT REALLY EXCITES A LOT
OF A SORT OF THE MOST RABID
SUPPORTERS ON THE LEFT, NOT
LEFT, THE MOST VOCIFEROUS HATERS
OF DONALD TRUMP.
BUT IT'S NOT HELPING THEM WIN
ANY NEW VOTERS IN THE MIDDLE.
WITH THE VAST COMPLEXITIES ON
THE BORDER, TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
SOME WAY TO FIX THIS PROBLEM
IF THE OTHER CHOICES MAXINE
WATERS GOING OUT AND SAYING,
PESTER THESE PEOPLE IN PUBLIC.
I THINK MOST VOTERS ARE GOING TO
SORT OF GO OR BE FORCED TOWARDS
THE TRUNK VERSION.
>> Bret: IF THIS DOES HAPPEN A
LOT IT SEEMS WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE
LOOKING AT A POLITICAL UPSIDE,
FOR A STORY THAT IS MEATY
CRATERING ON THE REPUBLICAN
HEIDI HEITKAMP AND JOE DONNELLY,
PARTY TO BE THE LEFT WING MIRROR
IMAGE OF THE THINGS THEY DON'T
LIKE ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
AND THAT IS THE CHALLENGE.
FIRST OF ALL, IT'S WRONG BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T LIKE IT WHEN
DONALD TRUMP DID IT.
SECOND OF ALL IT'S TACTICALLY
STUPID BECAUSE IT WILL BACKFIRE
HIS SUPPORTERS ARE THE VICTIMS
OF THE LEFT WING MOB.
SO IT'S NOT GOING TO LEAD TO
ANYTHING GOOD FOR DEMOCRATS AND
THAT'S WHY YOU SAW HER CALLED
OUT AND HOPEFULLY THEY WILL BE
THE MERITS.
>> IT'S ENCOURAGING THAT SOME
PEOPLE HAVE CHALLENGED WHAT THEY
HAVE SAID, AND DAVID AXELROD
NUMBER OF FOLKS ON THE LEFT TO
APPLAUD THE EXPULSION OF SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS FROM THE
RESTAURANT AND THEN WENT ON TO
THERE IS NO LONG-TERM UPSIDE IN
THIS KIND OF INCIVILITY.
POLITICS IS THE ART OF
PERSUASION AND OF THE PEOPLE WHO
MAKE LONG-TERM GAINS IN POLITICS
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO DO A BETTER
JOB OF PERSUADING OTHERS THAT
TAKE POLITICAL MOMENTS AND MAKE
THEM POLITICAL MOVEMENTS.
THESE ARE NOT ABOUT ARGUMENTS,
WERE NOT PERSUADING ANYBODY.
IF DEMOCRATS FOLLOW MAXINE
WATERS' ADVICE AND GET IN THE
FACE OF DEMOCRATS AND HARASS
THAT'S THE RIGHT WAY TO DO THIS?
AND IT GOES THE OTHER WAY TOO.
DONALD TRUMP MADE ONE OF THOSE
COMMENTS, DID HE ACTUALLY THINK
HE MIGHT CONVERT A DEMOCRAT THAT
COULD BE PERSUADED BY AN
ARGUMENT ON BEHALF OF HIS
POLICY?
SHORT TERM.
>> Bret: IT RIGHT.
I SAID I WAS GOING TO COME AS OF
LATE FRIEND OF
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAYS ABOUT WHAT
IT MEANS POLITICALLY.
>> THEY DON'T HAVE A MESSAGE,
THIS IS THE SAME REGION THAT
HILLARY WAS.
THEY ARE NOW FIXATED ON TRUMP
AND IT'S ALL ON THE RESISTANCE,
ALL ABOUT TRUMP.
BUT THINK OF THE BIG PICTURE,
WHY DO THEY WANT TO WIN THE
HOUSE?
ONE REASON.
NOT TAX REFORM, NOT JOBS.
THEY WANT TO WIN SO THEY CAN
START ON IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT AND UNDOING THE
ELECTION OF 2016.
THAT'S OF THE BIGGEST POLITICAL
MISTAKE AND POLITICAL STRATEGY I
HAVE EVER SEEN AND I THINK
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT A
WORTHY CAUSE.
>> Bret: ONE YEAR AGO THIS
WEEK.
THROUGH LONG COMPLICATED LEGAL
PROCESSES IS NOT THE WAY TO GO.
WE WILL ALWAYS BE DYSFUNCTIONAL
PEOPLE, AND THEY MUST BE STOPPED
AT THE BORDER AND NOT BE BROUGHT
ANY LEGALLY.
IF THIS IS DONE, ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION WILL BE STOPPED IN
ITS TRACKS AND, THIS IS THE ONLY
REAL ANSWER AND WE MUST CONTINUE
TO BUILD THE WALL.
>> IS SO LAST WEEK DONALD TRUMP
HAD EVERYTHING THROWN AT HIM BY
EVERYBODY BASED ON THESE IMAGES
DOWN ON THE BORDER, SOME OF
AND OF THE MOST SPECTACULAR OF
COURSE BEING THE PHOTOSHOP COVER
OF "TIME" MAGAZINE, WHERE IT HAS
DONALD TRUMP LOOKING AT THIS
GIRL WHO IS CRYING AT IT TURNS
OUT THAT CHILD WAS NEVER
SEPARATED FROM HER PARENTS AND
IN FACT, FOR THE REPORTING'S
SHOWS OF THE MOTHER HAD LEFT HER
OTHER CHILDREN BACK HOME WHICH
SUGGESTS THAT MAYBE IT'S A SIGN
SHE IS NOT GOING TO SUCCEED IN
GETTING ASYLUM AND DOESN'T
DESERVE ASYLUM BASED ON THE
CRITERIA.
BUT NOW AFTER A WEEK OF THE
HYSTERIA HAS SORT OF PAST AND,
WE ARE STILL DOWN TO A REALLY
COMPLICATED SITUATION ON THE
BORDER, I THINK THAT MOVED BY
DONALD TRUMP TO TALK ABOUT
KEEPING PEOPLE FROM GETTING INTO
THE COUNTRY SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
GIVE THEM DUE PROCESS, IT'S AN
ARGUMENT FOR BUILDING A WALL.
OR ANYTHING, SOMETHING THAT
PREVENTS THEM FROM GETTING
ACROSS THE BORDER BORDER.
>> I AGREE LAST WEEK WAS A BAD
PRETTY MUDDLED.
WE ARE STRONG ON BORDERS, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE WEAK ON BORDERS,
THAT SAFER GROUND FOR HIM.
A DON McGAHN ASYLUM PROCESS IS
TO SEE WHETHER THEY DESERVE TO
BE LET INTO THE COUNTRY OR NOT.
TO DECIDE BY FEE AT THAT THEY
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO, OR SEND
THEM OVER THE BORDER TO MEXICO,
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A
UNDERCOVER.
THE FORMER HOMELAND SECURITY
CHIEF JAY JOHNSON TALKING ABOUT
NOT ONLY CHILD SEPARATION BUT
STOPPING PEOPLE AT THE BORDER.
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT, THE IMAGES
AND THE REALITY FROM 2014 JUST
DETENTION.
WE HAD THEN 34,000 BEDS FOR
FAMILY DETENTION AND ONLY 95 OF
34,000 EQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH
WE BELIEVED IT WAS NECESSARY AT
FAMILIES.
WE CAN'T HAVE CATCH AND RELEASE.
>> WHILE THERE WERE NO PEOPLE
BEING KICKED OUT OF RESTAURANTS.
LOTS OF THINGS WERE MISSING BUT
ONE THING THAT WAS MISSING WAS
WHAT WE WERE SEEING WASN'T ON
PRECEDENT.
THE REASON IT WAS HAPPENING IN
INCREASING NUMBERS WAS
UNPRECEDENTED.
IT WAS A RESULT OF IT POLICY
DECISION THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAD MADE BECAUSE
I WANTED THIS TO SERVE AS A
DETERRENT.
THE ALL OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HAD
A DIFFERENT APPROACH TO IT AND
THEY ARGUED THAT WHAT THEY DID,
THEY HAD TO DO, AND IT WAS
REGRETTABLE.
BUT IT HAPPENED.
WE DIDN'T HEAR IT HAPPEN UNTIL
SEVERAL DAYS INTO THE DEBATE
WHICH WAS A FAILURE ON
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
CHARLIE IS RIGHT, THERE IS ALL
THIS NAVEL-GAZING AMONG
JOURNALISTS THESE DAYS ABOUT
WHAT THEY CAN DO TO RESTORE
CREDIBILITY.
WHILE THE FIRST THING IS GET THE
STORY RIGHT.
BY A MISLEADING IMAGE.